بالمعي الان من تونس العاصمه نور الدين
مباركي مراسل فرانس فانت كات نوردين اهلا
ومرحبا بك معنا اذا همم نور الدين
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات اعلنت عن قبول
اكثر من 1000 ملف ترشرش
المؤنث
الهيئه العليا
اثنين فقط
[موسيقى]
الاحزاب السياسيه وخاصه المعرفه تقول انها
ربما تكون حمله نشطه وان هناك مخاوف
حقيقيه سوا خلال هذه الحمله او خلال يوم
القياع من حاله العزوف هذا العزوف الذي
يفسره البعض في اعلان احزاب السياسيه
المعارضه مقاطعه هذه الانتخابات وايضا
يقول ان العزوف يعود الى اولا ان هناك سبع
دوائر انتخابيه كامله لا وجودا للمترشحين
فيها وايضا عشر دوائر فيها مترشح واحد
بمعنى انه لا تستحق حمد انتخابيه وهناك 10
نواب البرلمان مقبل القادم طبعا ايضا هذا
ياتي في سياق التشكيك في هذه العمليه خاصه
من قبل
المجتمع المدني وايضا احذيه السياسيه
العليا
مباشره من تونس العاصمه